so let's start with net margin this time
now it's the percentage of revenue
retained minus all expenses so the
correct answer is B here you calculate
net margin as follows take the total net
profit divide it by your total revenue
and multiply by 100 gross margin is
calculated as follows take your gross
profit divide it by your total revenue
and multiply by a hundred
now both metrics give us an indication
on our quality of performance many
companies tell you that we have a 40
percent gross margin on our products so
it can change from sector to sector but
you can always measure yourself against
other similar companies and see how well
or not well you're doing in relation to
them